The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: So if I can
have your attention please,
we are going to break from our
simulation for just a moment
to talk about our next module,
called Lean Engineering Basics.
There are two key
takeaways that we'd
like you to get
from this module,
and they're worth
reiterating and I
will say them several
times during the course
of the module.
The first thing we
want you to internalize
is that lean thinking applies to
engineering just as much as it
applies to factory processes.
And two, that engineering
plays a critical role
in creating value
in lean enterprise.
And our presentation
today is broken down
along those two lines.
And I'm going to start talking
about why lean thinking applies
to our engineering processes.
Here are our learning
objectives for this module.
They are five-fold.
So at the end, you
should be able to explain
how our lean principles and
practices apply to engineering.
You should be able
to explain why
customer value and this
upfront part of engineering
and the conceptual design are
critical to product success.
You should be able to describe
how lean engineering enables
lean throughout the whole
enterprise and the product
lifecycle.
Fourth, you should be able
to describe some tools we
use for lean engineering.
And lastly, you should be
able to apply lean engineering
techniques to redesign
your simulated airplane.
So we'll spend the first half
of this module talking concepts.
And we'll spend the
second half of this module
in an active learning
exercise, trying
to apply some of the
things we learned
to the redesign of your
simulated airplane.
A few days ago,
we had a question
about wastes in
engineering compared
to wastes in the factory.
And this chart is actually
the answer to that question.
We did say we'd
defer it a few days,
and now we're
going to tackle it.
So here are five
lean thinking steps
we talked about in
the first day, what
they mean for the manufacturing
process, and then lastly,
how we translate those
over into engineering.
Now, one of the
challenges we've had
in applying lean
to engineering has
been a reaction from the
engineering group that says,
well, you know, you can
apply lean in the factory,
but engineering
is just different.
You can't really apply it here.
And yes, of course, engineering
is different than the factory
operations.
But that doesn't mean that
these lean principles-- which
are very universal,
and you've seen
applied across the enterprise
from office processes
to manufacturing--
why they can't
apply to engineering as well.
The difference, mainly, from
manufacturing to engineering,
is a thing that's flowing
through the system.
So in a manufacturing
context, you
have the raw materials that
are flowing through the system,
and being processed and changed.
In engineering, it's
really information
that is flowing through
the value stream-- that
is being processed and changed.
Your design emerges,
uncertainties are reduced,
expectations are
clarified, and so on.
These are all examples
of the information
that's flowing through your
engineering value stream.
So for manufacturing, the
addition of value at any step
is pretty visible.
We told you that you
have to look and see
if a thing is physically
changed to add value.
And you can usually see that as
your material gets processed.
This is a little bit harder
to see in engineering.
When you change
part of your design
or when you do an
analysis, it's not
quite as easy to see that
you've change the information.
But you usually have.
The second contrast in that
manufacturing, your goal
is very defined.
When you start
manufacturing, you
have a very specific set
of specs and drawings.
And at the end, you
expect to come out
with exactly the product that
you wanted to when you started
the manufacturing process.
Now this is different
than engineering,
because in engineering
our goal is emergent.
We have some sense that
there are requirements,
and we have maybe some notion
of how we might meet those.
But the whole process of
engineering and design
is to look at
different alternatives
and to then come up with a set
of specifications for product
that you can build.
So your goal is really
emergent in that sense.
Now, we go down to
the value stream.
You can do a value stream
map for information
just like you can
for material flow.
The one difference is what's
actually flowing through that.
Now, if we move on to our
concept of flow, which
is trying to make
everything seamlessly go,
in manufacturing, iterations
are usually considered waste.
They're indicative of
rework in the process,
or a process or design that
wasn't spec'd right up front.
But in engineering,
as you all probably
recognize, mostly being
engineering students,
iterations are OK.
We plan to do these.
And that's a key word there
is that planned iterations are
good.
We recognize that
going through analysis,
and looking at problems,
and looking them
again is important.
The key there is that you
want your planned iterations
to be as efficient as you can.
The fourth concept of pull,
which in a manufacturing sense
is driven by tag time, for the
engineering processes, that's
usually driven by
your enterprise
needs for new products
to be developed.
And then, the concept
of perfection,
which in a manufacturing
context means
processing without repeating
errors, how does that
translate into engineering?
We would think of it as
engineering processes
that enable your whole
enterprise improvement.
And I'm going to expand on
that concept in the second half
of the lecture.
Here, we're revisiting our seven
wastes that we identified--
over-production,
inventory, transportation,
unnecessary movement,
waiting, defective outputs,
and over-processing.
So I'd like you
all to think back
to your engineering experience,
either from classes or maybe
from summer jobs.
And I'd like to hear some
examples, in an engineering
context, of any of
these seven wastes.
Go ahead, please.
AUDIENCE: So yesterday, at
the New Balance factory,
we were on the right
side of the factory.
We were talking about how
the upper part and the lower
part of the shoe was actually
manufactured in China.
But then, they shifted back over
here just to essentially glue
the top and bottom
parts together so
that they can say, assembled
in the United States.
And our group asked if wasn't
that a waste in transportation,
the cost, and the time,
and all that kind of stuff
just so they could say,
assembled in the United States.
And they want-- they felt that
it was worth it that they could
just say, you know--
that they put the US
logo on it in turn
for having that
transportation waste.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Interesting,
OK, so that to me
has some elements of
both manufacturing
and the engineering
design, and perhaps
some business strategy to it.
Can we try to think of
just isolating examples
to the engineering process.
Think about conceptual design.
And let's talk
about some examples.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Well, at my
internship last summer,
they were talking about
how a lot of older people
had really great skills
in specific areas.
And they were worried that
the older engineers weren't
communicating those skills
to the younger engineers.
And so when they left,
there would be waste,
because people would
have to relearn
that specific engineering skill.
So they created a
Boeing Wikipedia,
and were encouraging
engineers to type up articles
to try to keep that information
that other people needed.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: That's a
very interesting example.
Let me ask the class--
these are the seven
waste categories.
What do you-- which
category do you
feel that example might fit in?
Inventory-- having more material
or information than you need?
Any other thoughts?
OK, Earl, you have
an important--
AUDIENCE: Just that
New Balance, we
heard an eighth
waste category, which
was, for their environment,
unused associates creativity,
which was sort of a
loss of human-- a waste
of human resources.
Would this fall
in that category?
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Yeah,
to me it falls in eight.
I might also say it perhaps
falls in one, if I thought
that I had to produce
two engineers,
and the information
wasn't officially being
passed between the first
one who got the knowledge.
And then, I had to go
through the exact same steps
to get the second engineer
that same knowledge
without taking any advantages.
But this is one of the
interesting examples
of translating
largely manufacturing
a material-based instances
of waste into engineering, is
that sometimes is a
very clear translation.
And sometimes it's
a little harder
to figure out where it is.
But I think we can all agree
that example that Emily gave,
it's feels like
there's something
that's being wasted there
in an engineering sense.
A lot of experience--
and engineers' knowledge
is very experiential--
is being gathered,
and then sort of just
left to go away and not
be utilized by the company
anymore.
Let's take another example.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering, could that
be thought of as
over-processing as well,
because you need
to kind of do more
from scratch training
of the [INAUDIBLE]??
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Yeah, I could
take that argument, definitely.
Can you-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I guess I
may be missing a point.
So I just want to
clarify, how does it
help me to solve the
problem by classifying it
in one of these seven ways?
For example, if I know what
the problem is I'm throwing out
talent, I'm throwing
out knowledge
that I've got to then
retrain, how can I use these--
sort of this classification--
to help me solve it?
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Sure,
what you're doing
is you are standing on the
shoulders of giants of people
who spent decades of
years, and probably
millions of hours of brainpower,
trying to figure this out.
So let's start with
this is our analogy.
And then we'll probably create
unique categories of waste
that apply to engineering.
But this is a great
start, where in absence
of some classification
system, you
may spend a lot of time trying
to figure out what that is.
So it's really just a
creative tool for us
to help understand the
parallels to engineering.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's more of, like,
finding waste you use these.
If you like looking
at your organization,
you would look through
this and be, like, oh, OK,
I see this, and this,
and this, and it
helps you find new waste
instead of just analyzing waste
that you probably [INAUDIBLE].
ANNALISA WEIGEL:
Excellent, thank you.
Let's have another
example of a waste
that's different than
the ones we talked about.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Mine would
be either waiting
or an unnecessary movement.
I was working with GE
Nuclear in California.
And every time we were
doing a purchasing order
or test specifications
that had to be approved,
it had to be approved in
Georgia, which is a three hour
time difference.
Which means that either you have
to come to the office at 6:00
in the morning if you're
wanting your thing
to be processed right
away when they open,
or you have to stay up
later at night to finish it.
So everybody was very
upset about that.
We were losing six
hours in a day of work.
And the tests were being
done in Massachusetts.
So the engineers had
to fly over there,
spent some time running
through the tests
and get the results back.
And it was a waste
of time for everyone,
and energy, and other things.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Great,
great, and a good example
of waiting-- waiting is a
very common kind of waste,
if you think about information
and design that's happening.
How about other examples?
AUDIENCE: I work here at MIT,
and the first week, I had
to buy something for a project.
And no one how to buy anything.
Like, my advisor didn't know.
Eventually, they found out
that the woman in charge
had just moved, and no
one had replaced her.
So I guess it was waiting,
or a defective output,
or something like that.
ANNALISA WEIGEL:
There's several kinds
of problems with that
particular process, yeah.
Unnecessary movement also
happens quite frequently
in an engineering sense,
as well as transportation.
So if you think about how many
times you move information,
change information from the
inputs of one analysis program
into a format that's compatible
with another analysis program--
think about going back and forth
here on campus between MATLAB
and Excel happens frequently.
Now, if you go out into
a very complex industry
like aerospace, the tools
are far more complex.
And translating the inputs
of one of the outputs
to another, and so
on, is a large deal.
They're not necessarily
made to be compatible.
And then, we heard
[INAUDIBLE] talk
about a lot of
unnecessary movements
that may happen-- moving
people to various places
to test things to get analysis
results for your design.
Because sometimes
these complex products
are so large and
expensive, we can't
afford to have testing
facilities locally
to try to minimize
that kind of waste.
All right, we're
starting to get a sense.
And we'll talk
about them further
as we go through the
simulation game and the rest
of our module today.
I wanted to point
out some data that we
have about the efficiency
of engineering processes.
If you have any doubt that
there's waste in engineering,
this should help
convince you that there
is at least by some
informed people.
So this is a measure of
effort that's wasted.
40% of the product
development effort
was classified as pure waste.
About 30% is necessary waste.
In another survey, we had
30% of product development
time that was charged to
just set up and waiting.
You can easily see why those
don't add a lot of value
to the customer.
And not only is effort
wasted, but time is wasted.
62% of tasks, on average,
were idle at any given
time in a survey of
particular companies.
And 50% to 90% of
task time is found
to be idle in various
Kaizen-type events that
are run in an
engineering context
at different kinds of companies.
So clearly, lots of
room for improvement
here in the process
of engineering.
There's been a good body of
research done here at MIT.
And they produce the Product
Development Value Stream
Mapping manual.
And this is authored by Hugh,
who's in the back of the room.
The same basic techniques apply
as you might do value stream
mapping in the factory context
to the engineering context,
except that the flows
are information rather
than physical, and
your value added
steps help to transform
this knowledge
or to reduce the uncertainty,
which is a primary role of why
we do analysis in engineering.
And if you're interested, you
can consult this publication.
There's a lot more
material here than we
can cover in this module.
But let me give you
some real-life examples
of organizations that have
applied product development
value stream mapping
and had some successes.
So this is an
example on the F16.
And they had some
particular problems
with what they call their
build-to-Package process.
So if, for some
reason, they needed
to make changes to
the build-to-packages,
like you all have in
front of you for your SIM,
there was a big,
long process that
actually had to happen
from I need a change to,
OK, I can actually
make a change.
It numbered a lot of steps.
You can kind of
count them all here.
It goes here, and then
it goes down there,
and then it goes all
the way through there,
and all the way through there
before we get out to a change.
So applying some of the tools
of value stream mapping,
the F16 build-to-package process
was reduced down to something
like this.
So now, we had
single-piece flow being
able to go through the system.
We had an allowance for
parallel processing of tasks,
rather than single
processing of tasks.
Concurrent
engineering principles
were brought in to help
achieve this kind of leanness
in process, as
well as co-location
of all the various different
units between design,
and manufacturing,
and quality that
needed to be co-located
to accomplish this.
And if you wanted
some illustration
of the results that
can be achieved,
we have that here in this slide.
So this is actually
a picture here
of the build-to-package
support center
that resulted from this value
stream mapping activity.
It's a facility that's
down on the shop floor.
So it's very close to the things
that they're trying to change.
They created these kinds of
improvements-- in cycle time,
from getting a change request
in to having implemented that,
75% reduction of cycle time.
Process steps were reduced
by 40%, handoffs by 75%,
and travel distance of the
information, and paperwork,
and so on was reduced by 90%.
These are very, very
real kinds of savings
that can be achieved in
the engineering process
by the application of value
stream mapping techniques.
Now, we're going to move
on to the second concept
that we'd like you to take away.
And that is that engineering
plays a critical role
in creating value
in the enterprise.
So we've just seen how we can
apply some of our lean thinking
techniques--
including value stream
mapping, the concepts of waste,
and so on-- to the process.
But then, there's a
really important reason
why we want to lean out
the engineering process.
Because it's a key
enabler for lean
in the rest of the enterprise.
The reason for that is
represented here on this chart.
So we have on the
y-axis, essentially,
the percentage of
your lifecycle budget
that you might
attribute to these.
And here on the x-axis,
we have lifecycle phases,
starting from
concept development
through detailed design,
production use, and disposal.
Here, we show various curves.
So as you go through the
engineering design process,
you as engineers
are making choices.
You decide to use a
particular material.
You decide on a
particular design.
That has manufacturing
implications, performance
implications, and so on.
And as you make
those choices, which
are right here in
conceptual design,
you are determining
a priori the cost
of that system by your choices.
At the same time as we
move through this process,
the leverage that management
has to make any changes
starts to go down
dramatically, because a lot
of the knowledge and the cost
is being committed there.
But as cost is being
committed early,
it's really not being
incurred by your organization
for a while.
Because you're not
buying materials,
you're not bending metal, you're
not into the expensive parts.
That starts to happen over here.
But yet, you've already
decided it way back here
in conceptual design.
And a similar curve is
shown for knowledge.
This is what we know
about the design
of the product, the performance,
the quality, the use,
the reliability, and so on.
As you start out
early in a design,
you just don't know
a lot about it.
It's a process of discovery,
and analysis, and refinement.
And that knowledge grows
as you go further down
in the lifecycle phase.
But it doesn't grow nearly as
fast as you're committing cost
to that.
So there's a lot
of uncertainties
that exist in the process.
But it's this extreme
leverage that we
have up here in
concept development
to determine all of the
properties of our system
that's so fundamentally
important.
And this is why
lean thinking needs
to start with engineering.
Because the engineers are
making those critical choices
that are going to determine
cost, and performance,
and reliability, and safety, and
usability, and maintainability,
and so on.
So lean engineering is really
about doing the right thing
right.
It's got three components to it.
You first have to create
the right products.
You have to do that with
effective enterprise
and lifecycle integration.
And you have to use efficient
engineering processes.
And we're going to take
each of those in turn.
So creating the right product
means focusing on the customer.
And to do that, you have to
shift some resources up front
to the conceptual design
process so that you can spend
enough time to really
make the right choices
about the product.
Effective enterprise and
lifecycle integration
means that we should
use our lean engineering
tools so we can create
value throughout the product
lifecycle and enterprise, and
being efficient while we do so,
so apply the lean thinking
to eliminate waste
and improve the
processes of engineering.
So starting out
with our first point
about creating the
right products,
how do you know what's right?
The customer is the one
who specifies that for you.
And generally, when they're
thinking about value,
they have got four
large elements in mind
that sum up to be their value.
There are some elements of
features, and performance,
and quality.
There's some element of
schedule and when I can get it.
There's an element of cost
that they have to pay for that.
And then there's some
element of price--
of what it costs
you to make that.
And if you think to any
purchase that you make,
you are either consciously
or unconsciously balancing
all these parts
that equate to value
of a product in your mind.
So you may want a
computer that has
a certain kind of
performance and price to you.
But if you can't get
it for four weeks,
you may decide that that's
not really a good value
proposition for you.
And you may choose to set some
other combination of attributes
for yourself that
really defines value.
Engineering drives the
cost of all the products.
So 80% of the product's
cost is determined
through the engineering design
when these choices are made.
So the number of
parts that you have,
every part costs some money.
Parts have to be inventoried.
Parts have to be designed.
Parts have to be transported,
they have to be maintained,
they have to be quality
controlled, and so on.
And each of those actions incurs
a particular cost, as well as
tolerances on parts.
I'm sure some of you who
have gone through engineering
classes have talked about how
strict tolerances can really
increase the cost of
producing a product.
Whereas if you relax
tolerances, you
may get to a slightly
lower cost on your parts.
You can think of assembly
techniques-- different assembly
techniques cost different
amounts of money,
some are much more complex
and complicates-- as well as
processes to treat
raw materials,
and the tooling approach
that you might use, again,
that ranges from cheaper
to more expensive.
Materials-- if you want to
build something out of titanium,
it's going to cost
you differently
than to build it out
of other materials.
Avionics and software,
design complexity,
whether or not you're reusing
previous design efforts--
these all contribute
to the product's cost.
And these are choices that
the engineer is making.
So this is, yet again,
another illustration
of why it's so important to
try to make the right choices,
spend the amount of time you
need to do that up front.
This is a reflection back
to our suppliers talk.
Don't forget suppliers.
They're a critical
component of your design
and ensuring that you have
the right cost on your system.
Typically, 60% to 80% of
value is added by suppliers.
So when you think about
the engineering processes,
don't neglect them.
One of the best practices
for achieving the engineering
result that you want is to use
integrated product and process
development.
It's a concept that utilizes
a couple of elements-- first,
the principles of
systems engineering
to translate your customer needs
into a product architecture
and a set of specifications;
using integrated product teams
so that you can bring
knowledge from all
the different lifecycle parts
into your engineering activity.
Remember, we talked
about the cost committed
early on in the engineering
activity and the uncertainty
of knowledge.
One way to increase the
amount of knowledge you have
is to bring people in from all
the different lifecycle phases.
So bring someone in
from manufacturing.
Bring someone in from the
customer community who uses it.
Bring somebody in from
all the different parts
so that you can increase your
knowledge as early as you can.
Third, the IPPD approach
utilizes modern engineering
tools.
And we're going to give
some examples of that
in a few slides.
And it all can't really
function unless we've
got the right kind
of human resources
on board, which may
require a certain skill set
or certain set of people.
So it's not just that
you have capable tools,
you need capable
processes, and you
need capable people to actually
execute this successfully.
So here's a list of some of
our tools of lean engineering.
And I'm also going to show a
couple of detailed examples
in the next couple of slides.
So we have digital
tools that increase
the timing of handoffs, decrease
waiting, increase quality.
There are production simulation
tools that you can use,
which are much
cheaper on a computer
than actually having to go
out, and build a physical part,
and try to play
around with that.
You can think about
common parts and specs
in reusing design, the design
for manufacturing assembly,
which we're going to talk about
in the context of our planes,
and so on.
All of these are very useful
tools for lean engineering.
And to show you that these are
being used out in industry,
this is an example from Boeing.
This shows you how
they brought together
various different
digital tools that went
into producing the hardware.
So they were able
to use a CAD program
to do different layouts
and three-dimensional
visualizations.
They had a parametric
solids modeling tool.
They had some assembly models
that were done in 3D CAD.
They electronically release
their build-to-packages.
They used a computer to simulate
the manufacturing and assembly.
And all this was done
with far less cost
than trying to go and
build your hardware,
and do all of your playing
around in the physical space.
So I'll give you an example
of the production simulation.
I need to break a moment
and go into my movie.
Let's move on to another tool
of lean engineering, that's
common parts and
reusing designs.
So if you're using
common parts, and you're
reducing the total
part count as a result,
you're reducing costs, because
every part that you don't have
to design, you don't have to
manufacture, and QC, and tag,
and everything.
These are some
great illustrations
of trying to use what
we call mirror parts.
Do you need to have parts
designed differently
for the right hand side
and the left hand side?
Could you reconceive
your design such
that they used a common part?
And this would then save on
the number of unique parts.
Also have to realize that
common parts can increase
the quality of your design--
less points of
potential failure,
uncertainty, fewer moving
parts in your manufacturing
process, less room--
I'm sorry, fewer
mistakes to be made
in mistaking one
part for another
if I've got all common
parts and so on.
So let's talk about
part count reduction.
This is largely a goal
of what's called design
for manufacturing and assembly.
So I'd like some
input from you guys
on why we would
reduce part count?
We've covered a lot already, so
you can kind of shout them out.
AUDIENCE: Faster assembly.
ANNALISA WEIGEL:
Faster assembly.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Easier
for your supplier.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Easier
for the supplier.
Thank you, Mr. supplier.
Thank you, that was good.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Less variation--
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Less variation,
AUDIENCE: --to get
tolerance build-ups?
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Yes, indeed.
Does everybody catch that, the
concept of tolerance build-ups?
If you're reducing
the part count,
each part has a specific
tolerance to it.
The more parts you
label together,
kind of that-- the
bigger that uncertainty
in potential tolerance grows.
If fewer parts, that comes down.
What else?
That is good.
AUDIENCE: Less chance
of delivering mistakes?
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Fewer
chances to make mistakes,
because every part I handle
has some probability that I'm
going to make a mistake with
it, and I have a few of those.
Yeah, what else?
AUDIENCE: In many designs,
increasing part count
requires increased lubrication.
And oftentimes,
joints and things--
the more parts
you have, the more
need for lubrication,
more work, [INAUDIBLE]..
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Sure, so
operational considerations
that you might want
to think about.
And what are others?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Simplifying
the supply chain?
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Simplifying
the supply chain, yep.
Others?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Depends
on situation, it
could be cheaper [INAUDIBLE].
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Right,
yes, it reduces cost.
That's what your boss
really wants to hear.
It's going to reduce some
cost for the enterprise.
We've covered
almost all of these.
They were-- excellent
discussion, and some others
that we brought up that
aren't quite on this list.
It's important to
keep in mind, though,
that sometimes, but not all the
time, reducing your part count
would require some
performance trades.
So cost and schedule
savings may be big,
but you may be trading off
a little bit of performance.
And if your customer
is OK with that,
then everybody wins in the end.
One particular aspect
in aerospace systems
is, of course, mass when
you're thinking about that.
And sometimes, going to
common parts and fewer parts
can increase mass, which
may sort of dictate
a performance ding to the
system, but like I said,
not always.
And I think I'll show you
an example later on that
demonstrates that
really clearly.
So what I want to do now is
take you into an active learning
exercise.
And we're going to think about
applying these lean engineering
principles and
practices to redesigning
your airplane with a goal
for part count reduction,
and designing for
manufacturing and assembly.
So your first goal is
to satisfy the customer.
And the customer has
a couple of desires.
They want the mold line of the
airplane to remain the same--
exactly the same.
So this is the outer shape.
The customer also requires
that the landing gear--
but just the landing gear--
must be brown.
So it comes from a
particular kind of material,
and the customer
feels that they really
need the strength of that
material on the landing gear.
So those have to stay
the way they are.
Thirdly, the customer has the
desire for in-service quality
to go up.
Right now, the airplane
is kind of fragile.
You may have been
handling a full airplane
and noticed that the
tail section tends
to break off quite easily.
Hugh will demonstrate.
Oh, my goodness.
[LAUGHS] So the wing is also,
apparently a fragile part.
It depends on where
you hit the airplane.
But for example, I was
sitting at the customer
mat at one table.
I took delivery of an aircraft.
And as soon as I grabbed it,
the tail section fell off.
This is a real thing.
So perhaps, you can address
the customer's desire
for a slightly
more robust design.
And fourthly, as
we've been talking
about from the
beginning, the customer
really wants 12 airplane
to be delivered per round.
So they want you to increase
the delivery quantities.
You want to think about reducing
your manufacturing cost,
because this is good
for your enterprise.
So your parts are going
to cost $5 per part,
regardless of part.
Less parts then equals
more capacity for you.
And thirdly, we want you to
incorporate the suppliers.
What kinds of
innovations could you
generate by working better
with your suppliers?
Could you reduce
a part desercity?
What else could you do applying
lean engineering principles
in concert with your supplier?
So I'm going to give
you about 20 minutes
or so to talk in your teams
and redesign your aircraft.
You're going to work
with your facilitator.
And you need to
demonstrate that it
satisfies all of these
criteria for the customer.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANNALISA WEIGEL: All right,
everybody take your seats
again, please.
I could tell you're all having
fun redesigning your airplanes.
Let me use the next
couple of slides
to finish out this
module to give you
some motivation for why lean
engineering has been helpful
in practice.
I'm going to cite a couple
of real world examples here.
The first is an exercise
in design for manufacturing
assembly to reduce part counts.
In the latest iteration
of the F-18, called
the E/F, the company
the builds that
went on a part count
reduction exercise
by employing design for
manufacturing assembly
techniques.
In each of the major
assemblies for the plane,
they went and reduced
the part counts
from the C/D version, which
was a previous iteration,
to the E/F version.
So in total, we went from having
14,000 plus parts in the C/D
version, to having just over
8,000 parts in the E/F version.
This was a 42% part
count reduction.
Now, we talked before about
how sometimes, part count
reductions come with
sacrifices in performance.
But this was not the case.
So the F-18 E/F
version turned out
to be 25% more capable than
its previous predecessor.
So this was an excellent
win-win situation.
And not only was the customer
happier about the increased
performance, they were
absolutely delighted
by the lower cost of the plane,
because parts that are not
on the plane don't
have to be designed,
they don't have
to be tooled, they
don't have to be
NC programmed, they
don't have to be manufactured
or assembled, anything.
They don't have
to be stored, they
don't have to be
inventoried, they
don't have to be controlled, and
they don't have to be scrapped.
And if you have
fewer parts, they
don't need to have spare parts
for those extra parts as well.
So that reduced maintenance
and repair costs.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Does the
manufacture necessarily
have to pass on the cost to
the consumer [INAUDIBLE],,
because I imagine quite
a bit of time and money
goes into R and D to try to
get the cost [INAUDIBLE]..
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Yeah,
so there certainly
was a lot of engineering
costs to redesign the plane.
And there was an
interesting arrangement
between this company
and the government.
So there was some,
if you would call it,
cost-saving sharing or
profit sharing that went on.
So the company was
incented and rewarded
for keeping costs down.
They didn't have to give
all that savings back
to the government.
They didn't get to
keep it all either.
But they got to
keep enough that it
was an incentive for them to
actually meet these objectives.
And at the time,
this was somewhat
of a radical way of thinking
about government contracting
as well.
And that's not a trivial
area to overlook.
Because sometimes, those
contracting and legal issues
can keep you from
doing what otherwise
might seem very lean to you.
Let's look at another
example of how
lean engineering tools helps
reduce the manufacturing label.
So what I'm showing
you here on the y-axis
is account of manufacturing
labor in terms of hours.
And on the x-axis is the
number of production units
that we have.
So right here is where the
first physical production
unit is made.
This blue line right here
shows the labor hours
per production unit before lean
engineering processes and tools
were applied.
This curve down here
shows the results
after lean engineering
processes were applied.
And what happened was that
nine units were actually
built virtually before anything
got to the manufacturing floor,
such when they did get to
the first physical unit
that was produced, the
total manufacturing
hours to do that
was significantly
less than previously, before
learning the lean tools.
And in addition, the sort of
steady-state manufacturing
hours required for the same
comparable kind of product
was much lower, in the end, than
using the non-lean processes.
This is another example
of how better engineering
tools help reduce some
of the costs associated.
So on the y-axis here,
we have a staffing level.
And on the x-axis
here, we have months
from the end of the
conceptual design phase.
And this just shows the
results of the design and IPT
labor that was required for
vehicles of comparable sizes.
And what you see is
that, as we slowly
introduced different kinds
and better of lean engineering
tools, we were able to
reduce the staffing level
and shrink the time
that was required
to accomplish that milestone.
And lastly, lean engineering
enables faster delivery times.
And particularly
because spacecraft
have such a slow
reputation in the industry,
I thought I'd show
you a space example.
This is Iridium, which
is a satellite program.
And where it's typical to
have 12 to 18 months of cycle
time in the satellite industry,
this particular program
accomplished a cycle
time with 25 days, which
was just literally unheard of.
And they did it largely
through the application
of lean engineering and
lean manufacturing practices
to the program.
So just to wrap up, we
talked in this module
about lean engineering, and
how lean engineering can enable
lean manufacturing, and how
working with the supply chain,
all these three things
can come together
to create affordability of our
products across the enterprise
through the application of
lean, by reducing costs per unit
as we go down the assembly line.